if you've got a full-time job and you
want to start a part-time business and
you want to know what's the best
business that I can start on the side to
start making some extra money I'm going
to share it with you on this video today
hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I got a
great question for one of my LinkedIn
followers love you guys
yes seer who wrote in to say hello
pleasure to read your page I am your
seer from Pakistan I'm a salaried person
working from 9 to 5 I want to increase
my monthly income part time so suggest
me the business or any other ideas to
start part-time income with low
investment thanks yes here yes here this
is a great question one that so many
people have right you hate your job you
want to start your own thing you want to
be in charge of your own destiny and
you're not making enough money in your
current job and you want to have your
own business it's my time I want to rise
up I want to be in charge I want to make
money
finally right how do I get started
without spending a lot of money how do I
get started and do something the thing
is you're asking the wrong question
you're asking what industry should I get
into make a lot of money and anybody who
tells you that this is the industry that
you need to get in I'd really look at
what their experience is and what their
motives are do they actually know what
they're talking about and do they have a
financial incentive to tell you to go
into this industry the reality is you
can make money in any industry the key
thing in business that you need to
understand is that you will make money
when you provide value the more value
you can provide somebody the more money
that you are going to make so the
question becomes where can you provide
value so you can tell you usir the best
way to get started on the side is be a
piano teacher you can make lots of
income you can start part-time you know
you've low capital costs but maybe you
don't know anything about piano maybe
you don't love piano so how can you ever
be a great piano teacher and provide
that value what you need to do is think
about what are you really good at doing
what do you really love doing what would
you do in your part time what do you do
as a hobby if you didn't have this job
that you hate going to what would you do
with your day what makes you come alive
and then think about how can you help
people how can you turn what you
love into something that provides
tangible value for other people the more
you can help people the more money
you're going to make you want to make a
lot of money that helped a lot of people
you want to make a lot of money quickly
then help a lot of people quickly so
you've got to sit back and do a self
analysis really figure out what you love
and how you can use that love to help
somebody and I love the idea of you
starting part-time you don't need to
jump into this as a full-time business a
lot of people make that mistake they
quit their job they start their company
and then it takes way longer than they
thought it would for them to make some
money you start seeing your cash
reserves run out the bank account is
going dry and you have to go back and
get another job where it's way better
than start part-time build your business
up slowly and when you're making enough
that you can afford to leave your job
you're quits you can focus on your
business 100% so that's my advice to you
this year good luck and believe for
those of you watching my question for
you is how did you start your business
part-time what were the difficulties you
had what were some of the stresses you
had how did you manage that
with your job and your family leave a
comment below I'd really love to hear
from you about how you started that
business of yours part-time and if you
like this video and you want to see more
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and to the newsletter thank you so much
for watching I'll see you soon